all right now here's let's discuss Sam
was attacked behind my back tonight no
in both social media and in front of at
least one I'm now hearing it could have
been multiple theatres full of noise one
it was really one it was - you know into
the microphone okay first the mob you
would have just been killed for [ __ ]
snitching we're not in the mom listen
let me get bottle I'm not like everybody
but I want to say model Sam after
hearing what you said I apologize cuz I
was born I had a little piece and part
of this I appreciate that Bob know what
happened what happened why don't let me
tell you cuz I'm the one who did it
that's right no she did I go word was
misspelled I go on Twitter okay and Sam
who I like to call a troll he tweeted
hold on like that another attack Wow no
but he tweeted now that we're on YouTube
or whatever which force
spit out his food which I would think
from one of the co-hosts of the show
that I come in all the time and try to
help you guys and you help me and he
tweets something that negative and I
expect more out of him you know cuz he
is a clever guy not funny whatsoever but
he is they say something negative
he said now they were on YouTube you can
he said some negative he said I didn't
mean anything
well no I'll let you go before I talk
about the negativity of it then he said
you could see rich for spit out his food
and I said well you know what I deal
with this all day you have great fans
and you have people that have this
negative negative adage I was in the car
with him when it happened driving -
again I don't I mean you were a little
look you were a little mad it was he
missed on that I always thought I was
disappointed I was disappointed since he
was young
I was disappointed well look here's I'm
disappointed I don't know if those are
the words you use if you recall I think
it was a little more than that last time
rich was in studio do you remember that
he was about to tell a story maybe food
did fly out and let no no no no no no he
was about to tell a story and like he
tends to do he takes a giant bite before
he tells a story yeah sometimes your
timing is a little bit and we said why
would you do that and not a little food
fell out he took the lid of his precious
Bennett yeah
and he spit the entire mouth full of
food into the lid the cameras are on
yeah if you look at the quote tweet that
I put out uh-huh
the video was of that moment not of a
little food coming home as you smoke
right now I was wrong picking up the lid
there was a description and spitting
your food into the lid he was describing
a video like watch vos be stupid I clean
it out I didn't even know that video was
made until I saw one of our fans tweet
on a Saturday morning he had watched on
his big TV so the tweets so though the
tweet was supposed to be look you can
watch our videos on this big TV the
video is Voss spitting a mouthful of
food into a lid of a breakfast container
disgusting so I said oh my god thanks to
the at Sirius XM app you can now watch
rich Voss spit his breakfast out on
television oh yes that's what he did in
the video it wasn't like he was like
making this grand point and I'm like
let's ignore that because the little
food came out of his mouth it was a
video I'm glad we settled this home oh
it's my fault let me twin it when I can
sorry one more time when I tweet about
the video of this phase don't get upset
I'm just letting people know the videos
out there that I
apologize and I'm sorry you're out
that's right yeah you should hug it out
there you go that's nice
one more Jim and Sam catch up with full
episodes and interviews from celebrity
guests anytime on demand using the
SiriusXM app